- Is it true that you do crazy things
to celebrate connecting
with more people on TikTok?
- Yeah, so every time we
reach another milestone,
another million,
I do these things called
million meals where I create
like these outlandish desserts
or like crazy meals that,
you know, we all kind
of dream about having,
but never actually tasted it,
but it's been, it's been like,
it's been pretty crazy in terms
of how good they have been.
You know, a lot of people are like,
I don't know if I thought
like that amount of sugar,
trust me it is unreal.
It is.
It's so good.
- I don't think I've ever
actually said that sentence
in my entire existence.
I think I'm like elf,
like, I'm like if there's sugar I'm in.
- Same, same.
- Yeah.
Okay, so you did this
crazy thing on TikTok,
it's, it's a death jump on TikTok right?
Is that what it's called?
- Yeah, so basically,
so you drop a tissue from
the top of the stairs
and you have to like
run and try to catch it
before it touches the floor.
So,
(laughing)
everybody--
- That sounds like a workout.
- Yeah, so I mean TikTok has all of these
kind of crazy challenges that you can,
you know what I'm saying?
Do with the people that you care about.
So you're not just like
on Netflix all day long,
playing video games.
It's just active things to do,
especially during these times right,
but mine ended a little,
a little tricky, you know, I, I,
I ended my knee a little bit.
It was little painful.
(laughing)
- You're like all in,
you're one of those people that
play sports is like all in.
- Oh, oh, it's all or nothing.
I'm competitive.
- Oh man, me too.
Oh, it gets me in so much trouble.